good morning believe nation if you're
having a hard time staying committed to
your business and you're thinking about
giving up I'm gonna share with you an
inspiring clip from Will Smith that I
think will help the road to success is
through commitment and through the
strength to drive through that
commitment when it gets hard and it is
gonna get hard and you're gonna want to
quit sometimes but it'll be colored by
who you are and more who you want to be
I definitely found that wanting to be an
actor stems from wanting to be somebody
and wanting to say something to people
so one of the secrets that I've
discovered is that it's totally normal
to think about quitting and giving up
it's one of those dirty little secrets
that entrepreneurs don't talk about
you're always talking about the good
things in your business and the clients
that you've landed and your big vision
but not about how you're thinking about
giving up but it's something that every
entrepreneur goes through at least once
in their business as they build up I
remember in my first company I told my
business partner that I quit because it
was just too hard you know everything
that we had done just wasn't working we
started the business and and I thought
we're gonna make a lot of money we're
gonna help change a lot of lives we're
gonna have this huge impact and we're
we're pouring our hearts and soul into
this business it wasn't from a lack of
effort and we just weren't getting
results you know very very minimal
results working for less than minimum
wage and barely able to survive and it
just took a pounding on my
self-confidence and my self-worth and I
felt like I'm worth more than this I
feel like total crap so I'm gonna go do
something else because this isn't
working for me but the next day I woke
up and I felt like I can't quit on this
this is too important I need to commit I
need to just find another way to stand
we've got to keep trying we got to bust
through and I went back to my business
partner what you know we worked out of
his condo and I went back again
and he accepted me back and we started
working and and we started finally
getting some results when I started
realizing I'm not the only one to have
gone through this and we started
modeling success what you have to
understand is that if you try to do
something big you're trying to do
something powerful you're trying to do
something important it's gonna come with
a heavy dose of failure it's gonna come
with a heavy dose of fear if it was easy
and you weren't scared then it's
probably not worth doing and it's
through failing and feeling and feeling
and trying new things and committing
yourself and double committing yourself
and triple commit in yourself that
eventually you find your success and if
you look at almost every successful
famous entrepreneur you look early back
in their careers you'll see a lot of
failures before they eventually hit it
so it's totally normal to think about
quitting it's totally normal to think
about throwing in the towel and what you
have to do is really think about is this
something that you really want to do is
this important is this meaningful is
this going to change your life in a
really powerful way and it's gonna help
out a lot of other people and if that's
the case then you got to commit you
can't give up you got to keep going
because you watching I'd love to know
your story of commitment I love to know
when you thought that thought about
quitting and giving up and what changed
your mind and what kept you going and
believing in yourself leave a comment
below I'd love to hear a person I'm
gonna be joining the discussion and I
think it could also serve with some
inspiration for other people who are
watching so thank you so much for
watching and continue to believe have an
amazing day and I'll see you tomorrow
morning again for another shot of in
spresso